3:28 kind of oh swearing 320 everybody
it's gary vay-ner-chuk APUs owed 328 of
the askgaryvee show and when I think
about this person I call her Jay Jay in
my mind even though this is literally
actually we stumbled into each other the
other day a tennis match but and then I
texted you and you didn't text me back
is that true yeah brick [ __ ] no real
reason I would love to text you back I
don't know how I miss them but I'm gonna
check that while we're doing this
episode JJ is like why don't you tell
the Vayner nation who you are and what
you're about and then we're gonna jam a
little bit my name is Jamila Jamila you
may know me from my TV show the good
place where I play the exact opposite of
Who I am in real life and I'm an
activist in my day to day existence and
a writer an orator mm-hmm writing I love
writing I used to be a journalist and I
used to be a TV host and then I stumbled
into acting purely by mistake was that
was that ever subconsciously going on no
no way no no I had no desire to do it
because I felt like that was something
that you really trained to do and I I
really don't know respected the craft
and I respect and you didn't want to put
in the work I disliked effort is when
you have natural ability in it overly
tall annoying English woman from
Pakistan and I think so I accept that
insult when that when that when that
opportunity came was there any debate to
do it would it feel natural to do it
like where were you and your mindset in
life that made you go there I ran out of
money in pursuit of trying to raise
money for people with disabilities to
have more access at big music venues and
I spent all of my money trying to make
that happen and it didn't happen because
people are so ablest in my country and
every country but in particular the UK
has got listed buildings and they use
that as a defense mechanism to not
update their buildings in order to be
accessible for people with disabilities
and so I lost all of my money doing that
and
came to America with no money and no
exact plan I wanted to be a writer I had
a pilot that I'd written I got signed to
three arts and they heard about and ETA
and they heard about this this audition
they sent me for it I was a big fan of
Mike Schur and I'd you know I'd never
thought in a million years I would
actually get it but when it came to the
point where I'd signed the seven-year
deal before the final audition they make
you sign a seven-year deal before that
final audition so all the power is
within their hand course and I needed
the money and I was like if I fail I
will fail rich yeah you know when wasn't
that I that was three years ago
understood and now we've done four
seasons and it's a hit show and I didn't
die on my ass yeah and I was able to do
what I wanted to do all along which was
I've been an activist since I was 19 and
I've only ever entered show business as
a way to leverage awareness awareness
around that I remember when I was 19 I
was watching that was around the time
that Angelina Jolie was starting to
raise awareness about things that were
happening in Cambodia and Pakistan and
there are Cambodian and Pakistani people
raid trying to raise awareness no one
listened to them we only listen to the
privileged I was like oh that's nice
that's not nice that's bad but like
that's an effective way that's the way
raise awareness is when you have a lot
of privilege than people listen to it's
easier to raise awareness from the
inside and so I got into this industry
in order to be able to make the noise
that I'm now able to make you know super
interesting the way especially the
reference point you're made with
Angelina and and prior to her the
thought of privilege it's super
interesting because we're now living
through a very interesting time of the
maturity of the internet itself which is
social platforms social networks that
have it's such scale in our society that
in the past privilege and wealth and
things that nature led to awareness
right led to scale of people paying
attention to you there we're really
living in this interesting time where
the definition of that a privilege can
almost get tweaked a little bit because
having sheer audience at scale even
before you've become or have started the
process of the monetization of that can
still create some of those effects and
so the attention becomes a trigger to
them
that leverage and privilege because
that's what it used to be but there were
so many gatekeepers and who became those
winning players whereas now you know
whether it's tick tock or LinkedIn or
YouTube that's wide open it's just wide
open and the paradigm shifts are gonna
be enormous and we're starting to see
significant nuances of that mm-hmm take
me back a little further
hey I just think it's interesting at 19
so I'm like now very curious about like
what happened or was it building you
know why at 19 did that happen was it a
cause that got you going
had it been subconsciously happening but
even before we go there because I just
love I do I very I really genuinely like
it you know I was born in the Soviet
Union so much of what everything I feel
has so much to do with the origin stuff
so I yeah I do like it so what kind of
where were you born what kind of kid
were you like what was your scene I was
born in London I was deaf as a child
flat out flat out deaf and then I would
sometimes have enough operations to get
my hearing back and then my hearing
would go again I'd have another
operation I had seven major operations
on my hip on my ears before the age of
twelve and it was the final operation on
my 12th birthday in which I managed to
get like 65% of my hearing back so I'm I
have impaired hearing but that was my
that was a big part my childhood which
contributed to me being a very quiet
child very socially inept child I was
very scary because I would stare at
people take them and I've maintained
that ability and still freak people out
I but it also made me a hyper observant
person which has stood me in good stead
in this like very dangerous industry but
and in the world as a woman so I was
unpopular spent a lot of time on my own
which which allowed me to kind of grow
my creativity and and just sort of allow
me to become exactly who I was I wasn't
shaped by other people around me cuz
there were no other people around me
your siblings I have a brother he was
older but he went to live in Spain when
I was very very young so we were kind of
separated so I kind of lived as an only
child for many years yes
and I did come from any money so like
you know parents were out working and
they separated when I was very very
young and I went to a special-needs
primary school and then I got into a I
got a full scholarship into school that
isn't for special needs kids and during
my time there I regained my hearing and
I was able to win a music scholarship
and an academic scholarship and I just
stayed there until I was seventeen
seventeen got hit by a car broke my back
didn't move and about two years I was
running away from Abby that wasn't
tracing me I just saw Abby and I
remembered home alone and I ran away
from it into traffic yeah Jesus I run
into traffic when I see flying insects
yeah that's to me that seems safer
understood I'm an idiot somebody thought
it was a good idea to walk in idea so he
got the picture left and he now knows
he's going to so you had a Abby you
decided was gonna be problems it
actually turned into a massive pocket
the rest of my life because that
accident was the single best thing that
ever happened to me and I I recommend it
to you all break your back yep and lay
down two years it really humbles you and
there's something about not being able
to piss on your own that really changes
the way that you feel about yourself and
your body and I think at that point when
I was lucky enough to come out of that
still able to walk I realized that god
I've really been mistreating my body
because up until then from the age of 12
until 17 I was severely anorexic I'm
sorry and starving myself all of the
times was the 90s it was all about
heroin Jersey tonically by grown adults
who were [ __ ] idiots and they were
putting that out for very young kids the
internet had just come up and so it was
all these like thinspiration websites or
remember I have a DD so you're gonna
like this is good you want to play okay
fine you're good okay
okay what's happening I'm just fidgeting
with this thank you cause while I'm here
I've got it's the I thought that was
gonna help No
Armidale Gary we're happy I'm gonna I'm
just fidgeting with my toes right now
yeah yeah go ahead I'm big on go ahead
I'm big on asking what I need listen I
might well I'm very good at delivering
on what people thank you guys it's
amazing okay so where was I you were
talking about inspiration and things of
that nature when I was lucky enough to
get better I realized that I
disrespected my body so profoundly up
until now and I was like okay that's it
I have to do something like what made me
think that starving myself was a good
idea why did I think that that was
beauty and that may be worthy like why
did I never care that I had a music
scholarship after being deaf most of my
life what I never care that I was an
academic kid who had like straight A's
all throughout school I was a good kid I
didn't value why was your perspective
looking at the half glass I wanted to be
ninety pounds that was my human be just
like basic worth and so I started
campaigning against the fashion industry
understand I entered the fashion
industry in order to do it I became a
model scout I started trying to scout
plus-size girls but I was ahead of the I
was ahead of the curve yep no pun
intended and so I used to so they said
no to all of the countries but I started
writing letters to magazines about what
I was seeing and they were making
twelve-year-old to cry about their
weight and yes I kicked off this I 0
debate with a letter that I wrote to the
Evening Standard in the UK and it turned
into this huge thing across the news I
was all over the news I was doing like
live channel 4 and this was in England
and BBC live I was 19 years old there's
still like little videos of this on like
Getty Images and I've been talking about
everything I'm talking about now for the
longest time the dumbest thing about
what's going on in my career right now
is that I have majority support like I
say 90% support but the 10% of people
who give me a lot of [ __ ] what a treat
man girl feedback from the world yes so
sure social media support I understand
this 90/10 when people take me try to
take me down they treat me as though I'm
someone who here ago was an actress in
the good place who just decided to pick
up activity because I thought maybe
trendy sure who's activism has become
trendy it's like I have been in this
[ __ ] for 14 years
some of you little haters might even
alive you know this is something I can
really connect with you on how does that
how do you think about that because
you're bringing it up now mm-hmm so I've
I'm empathy for that it makes sense to
me
don't you love though that the truth is
on your side I think in you know for me
the thing that you know and I kind of
live this life as well right now I'm
getting destroyed yes we're currently in
certain pockets because I think
sometimes it's strategic to do free work
to get your foot in the door which makes
me you know a complete vampire you know
no free work ever you know obviously
which is all done that we I think so but
many people who have not had to do that
who did not grow up the way I did who
don't realize they think they're
fighting for other people but what
they're actually doing is showing their
unbelievable privilege of never having
to be in that scenario it's an addition
process it's an audition process that
will do it until the day I die there I'm
not always looking for a check in return
for why I'm doing something yeah I mean
you sat here and talked about the thing
I believe in the most which is a
platform where you have awareness to be
able to do something the attention is
the number one thing yeah and yet so
nonetheless
you know but it's wrapped my feelings
people like you're the devil you're like
I'm like it makes me I'm a human however
um you know when people are like when
they say anything and we all will be
judgment is way more trendy oh and an
activist yeah you know than anything
judgment is the [ __ ] number one thing
that's happening in society that's scale
as a matter of fact I'm actually a
little bit actually we're getting a
little bouncing around here uh I'm
actually weird my ID do you can follow
this you just can't move so make it
around check it how about this I'm with
you Kerry okay right here are you ready
I'm actually scared that we are on such
hyper attack and judgment yeah what we
do as humans always is counteract the
other way and I find myself now and
honestly I was DNA wise and parenting
wise I think you're being pushed back
into like archaic beliefs because you're
being because you're fed up of the you
know get back in the kitchen but the
fact that you're making
connection does get me to a point I'm so
sad that everyone's judging everyone on
an adjective during a conversation not
even a debate amongst acquaintances
friends that I'm concerned because I
understand how humans are wired we're
gonna go up yeah I'm at a point where
I'm like struggling to judge anybody
about anything it's actually this weird
kind of like reverse thing that scares
me that it's the chess move to the bad
stuff yeah I'm like the macro is gonna
play out I mean so nonetheless I'm
ranting cuz you're bringing a lot of
thoughtful pretty honor together I like
it this is the kind of [ __ ] I like
talking about so my way of dealing with
this is that I was just like you've got
your truth on your side is where I'm
going hey I have truth on my side period
but no but there is always a billion I
am also a flawed human being I'm gonna
make mistakes I've made mistakes I have
receipts of mistakes that I've made
because the internet never forgets and
so what I've had to do is just accept
that some people are right when they are
criticizing me they are right and they
have a right to criticize me and I don't
take it personally anymore because I
can't because if you're going to be an
activist you have to leave your ego and
your pride at the door and so I've just
realized if I'm going to put myself out
there and put my opinions all over the
place I have to be willing to take some
[ __ ] back and it just doesn't I'm not
here to be liked I couldn't give a [ __ ]
about being liked I'm not interested in
it I've come here to create change so no
one ever goes through what I've been
through ever again so I don't really
care about that but also I have decided
to make it part of my I'm gonna look say
the word brand but I decided to make it
part of my brother he'll be with brand
presence on the blip on your throw up i
I'm so fascinated by societies I'm
ENGLISH though we are [ __ ] respect
but but I'm still an English and in
London is part of society we're like
yeah I'm fascinated by the semantics of
words people are unbelievably throwing
up on each other about personal brand or
brand yet if you just say reputation
it's remarkably consumable I am scolded
if I even go down the path of the word
hustle for being a bro yet if I change
it to work ethic
I'm admired for acknowledging that it's
part of the equation semantics of words
back to judgment
has become [ __ ] ridiculous but brand
is infused with capitalism as a word its
marinated in the idea of capital a
reputation said they're fine but like my
whole my whole stick we said am i saying
it's very good I like [ __ ] I am very
comfortable is that I am a flawed person
and the thing that I I constantly say to
people throughout my activism is we are
looking for progress not perfection
the search for moral purity will never
go anywhere because it doesn't exist and
also human beings continue to update we
have to continue updating ourselves like
iPhones and we have to keep learning
about new genders new sexualities new
ways which people want to live and we
have to learn how to unlearn our
previous programming around there and
and get with the program now and so I
very much so own my pinned tweet is all
of my mistakes so I'm just like come at
me bro like I'm not hiding from nice the
last scene of eight mile I bring up all
the time yeah the best way to play
exactly and so I'm just like I'm like
I'm just I'm that's awesome it's [ __ ]
amazing Thanks it makes you happier well
it's also like made my it's like help to
my career as weekly because more men
follow me than ever before like more
people who have made mistakes find that
my social media is a safe space to learn
because now we've made people too afraid
to even put their hands up and say I
don't know the answer a hundred sweet
chastised people for ignorant you can't
just die someone for something that they
don't even know yet and so you can
chaste I someone for deliberate willful
ignorance and you start getting into
this ideological place I'm saying what I
know and you know you completely lack
empathy we completely collectively lack
empathy yeah we make weak-ass judgment
through our filter Wilma yeah any
compassion or empathy or no it's
ridiculous and so willful ignorance is
the only one that I think you can
chastise people for because there's
always an ability to learn we have the
internet you've got no excuse if you
live in the West and you have the
internet and phone you know it's on us
to not update you're importing your
enemy say okay I choose to yeah
look at the other way because it's an
invested interest exactly and that's my
that's that's where I'm at and what
and very helpful to me whatever they
like do you like food music sports like
what what like just for five seconds
from my own curiosity food what about
the love board game
what is your feelings for Apple are you
cause you're [ __ ] great out of cuz
you're a [ __ ] writer yeah I play
Scrabble in the lick lick I get
dominated and then my friend will look
over he's like why didn't you make the
word cat I'm like [ __ ] like I'm like
don't work you're doing okay in other
areas by the way it's really fascinating
I it took me a long long time because of
the 80s because my mother was
embarrassed of her accent so she
wouldn't go to school nights because a
lot of things that happened a lot of the
things about myself I now know I had to
learn much much much later like I will
go and speak in Madison Square Garden
right now in front of 35,000 people
right now if you're like you have to go
do it in a heartbeat if you ask me to
read the first page of that comic book I
would shrivel this goes all the way back
to those things but to your point I'm
also wildly observant and it's because
the way I learn wasn't through like
words no like Sam yeah I have difficulty
reading I have difficulty reading music
and yet I could play like at a grade 8
level like what I can't read any music
I'm trouble ingesting information via
written word like you know are you
wildly competitive when you board game
yeah like no no I'm just in the breaks
my heart
I'm just really good I don't I know but
but are you worried are you competitive
no really mm-hmm
that's interesting yeah I think the only
thing I would ever say I'm competitive
about is that genuinely and I noticed
this via my addiction to Super Mario
when I was 16 is that I can I want to
beat my own score that's the only thing
I'm interested in that's fascinating
I took me a long time to get into a
health regimen that I felt was something
that was a smart decision for my
long-term life mm-hmm
it was always you know and I and it I
had this completely crazy breakthrough
which is I'm the complete opposite of
that I have no [ __ ] interest in going
faster by one second or jumping I want
to compete with all of you at scale on
tilt yeah and not with myself yeah I
think I think since I had therapy I I've
got no competition really in me at all
now all I genuinely want
to be happy and I cuz I didn't know that
that was a thing I didn't know that
happiness existed and therefore I didn't
prioritize it whatsoever when I was
younger and so therefore I thought
success was measured in how money how
much you can consciously do you think
about your legacy like the day after you
never I think [ __ ] yeah I think I
don't understand don't care about I'm so
sorry no I'm happy for you you know I
love legacy I just don't give a [ __ ]
about legacy I just I'll be dead and
I'll be oh no I won't know do you think
that though when one thinks of legacy it
dictates behavior that then they could
be proud of
interesting but also sometimes can
consume you because you sometimes miss
the things that can make you happy now
so that you can beyond your process is
what makes one happy well if that
process is what makes you happy then
that's fine but a lot of people I think
we can both admit like we know very
successful people a lot of those people
who are so dedicated their legacy are
not happy in the pursuit of society runs
deep yeah but that also insecurity can
sometimes be the the driver for legacy
like why do you need I'm not interested
when when somebody chooses activism or
wants to do things there's a lot of
different ways that can filter again I
don't show that Jenny I don't think one
is right over the other it was like it's
fun to think about like I I do think
about legacy I do want to live my life
in a way this is actually I don't even
know if it's legacy this is what runs
through me I don't know why this caught
me early on I'm fascinated by the notion
of which funeral you choose to go to
what like the Oscars party no I've no
idea what that is no isn't like they
have different parties after the idea
something like we were so it I don't
know not that I mean a funeral you get
an email right now yeah and your
fourth-grade teacher has passed away and
you decided that she or he brought you
so much value right that even though
tomorrow's a very busy day you decide to
fly to the UK or anything else why do
you care if your dad you don't know
don't forget about that oh yeah in the
macro right I am fascinated by the
concept and rarely hear anyone talk
about this No
of the decision-making process right
people go through when they choose which
funerals they go to versus not and I
don't know why I caught that as a young
kid but I would watch I'd be like why
didn't that guy go like why didn't that
business friend of mine go - that was
his best business partner for 15 years
like just even my own like there's been
you know different you know I'm
referring to one that very vividly
somebody had the business with a long
time who my dad was very close with like
why there's like seven eight years ago
why did I not choose to fly back from
San Francisco for that funeral like it's
a terrible day I understand that but
then which ones like there are people
I'm thinking about now and I don't want
to jinx it I'm very repeating that way
but like I would I would like you know
I'd rip off my arms and swim with
nothing like to get to its I'm
fascinated by that because I think it's
one of these kind of ultimate decisions
you know that person doesn't know I
think it's an interesting paradigm that
I've always been fascinated by and
that's I'm just bringing that up I think
for me like I'm not interested in
weddings or funerals like I'm not I
don't feel a drive to to make an effort
to get to either of them particularly I
know I do I sound like a sociopath not
only don't you a lot of the framework of
what you're talking about here connects
with me tremendously okay well I think
people make attachment to things that
are other people's ideologies
I love I actually I just like being here
thank you thank you for like honestly I
actually really resonate with where
you're going I I have the same thing I'm
unbelievably comfortable in the feelings
that I have and my truths yeah and I
recognize when sometimes they align with
the masses yeah and I'm equally and more
comfortably aligned I kind of love when
it's not no I'm Kay I'm confused by
these events I'm confused by them and I
don't know why but I'm just confused by
them I've never been to a wedding I've
never been to a funeral
oh no you've never been to a wedding no
one even wants to [ __ ] any of my friends
nevermind marry them you've never been
yeah no I never said that you've
actively made that something that you've
you've chosen to make that happen
yeah yeah there's like do you remember
when you first thought that that would
be cool and when I say cool no
yeah because I that's an important words
matter do you remember when you chose
and and had that conversation with your
own self of like oh I'm not gonna go to
weddings no I didn't it was never it
just never happened I just didn't like a
I mean I ended it but I've also never
invited them to my wedding you know I'm
in the same boat
we're just no hypocrisy groups but yeah
I'm just not interested I'm definitely
not interested in going to someone's
funeral because I think it's sad it
smells funny and the person you've known
habla how do you know I went to one when
I was nine my uncle's death and I was
like I'm done with this [ __ ] I was just
like this is just a bad day yeah
everyone's upset yes and this person
doesn't even know that I made the effort
to come here I'm getting no credit
whatsoever that's really a lot of people
know I want credit from the person I
cared about
then I'm out like sure I may be I know
that they got I also like show the way
no spirituality or religion in me
whatsoever I understand that what does
that mean does that mean that when
somebody that you're very close to for
30 40 years you find out they're sick
you're big your mindset goes to [ __ ] I
gotta go see them before they die yeah I
understand that's why I mean it makes
sense yeah yeah goodbye
I'm not saying goodbye after they're
like they're they're not talk to me
about a life your content consumption my
content consumption how podcasts social
newspapers magazines the Internet itself
text messaging ot T's Network movies
books you as an animal how and what do
you consume i Netflix an ill I'm a
chronically ill person and so I spend a
lot of my time on Netflix and that's how
I exist you manifest that was born with
a condition called ehlers-danlos under a
minute so you're ill drop the C in the H
yeah and you Netflix it yeah I Netflix
it on my own or with my very loving boy
yes but I also consume a lot of my
information on Twitter and Instagram
yeah and I find a lot of my favorite
writers via there and
my favorite speakers I found you on
Instagram by your videos I don't I
haven't yet found time to listen to
podcasts or actually like have anything
that I subscribe to and I have as a
routine and I would like to do that
something nice by the time you men have
you one have you one off the podcast
here and there no so you've never like
you know maybe by the way Nora by I have
never that's not true I think I listen
to like 15 minutes of a bar stool thing
but I I mean I'm under two hours of
podcast consumption I basically spend
95% of my time consuming comments my
content and others yeah I will hear
something in the consciousness you know
going to the bathroom and doesn't hey
did you hear about you know Meg the
stallion and I'm like no and then I'll
go google and or go on instagram find
her and then I won't even listen to her
music or why she's popping I'd consume
more comments of Liz oh yeah then Liz Oh
songs yeah I love consuming replies I'm
exactly the same
it's you're so interested in that and I
and I feel like gives us I apologize do
you feel like gives us a little bit of
like a usually quick insights the things
that people don't see yet I think I
think perhaps but I just know that
that's what I'm most interested in I'm
fascinated by people I'm fascinated by
mental health I'm fascinated by trauma
I'm I want to know how people work and I
want to help them work better and more
efficiently and be happier and that's
really all I'm interested in is just
like your happiness and your like orgasm
frequency and all of the different
things like I just want you to be happy
and so I read people's comments I ingest
a lot of information via social media
and I know that that's that you know
frowned upon by some people but this
idiot
yeah yeah it's for the great people on
Twitter and I think if you're someone
who has a thicker skin and doesn't have
your feelings hurt all the time if you
don't take Twitter personally Twitter is
just an amazing what's your heart taken
feelings hurt and thin-skinned like what
and so you said people are awesome
because I think because of the content
that I put out is like somewhat
intelligent sometimes sometimes I'm just
you know a Neanderthal but sometimes my
content is intelligent I've therefore
attracted intelligent
people towards me and I learn so much
from my own how community intelligent
people feel when you're saying something
that isn't intelligent they let me know
very quickly and very publicly a tiny
bit like and that feeling is faded that
was an original feeling of like that
sort of time burning in your chest where
you just feel humiliated and that was
the moment where I realized like if you
feel pride into this you're making this
about you yes and it's not supposed to
be about you you can't be standing up
for marginalized people thinking about
yourself and how your body represented
and so I left that alone and now I don't
care now I feel very free and happy for
you
what uh what have we not touched on you
know knowing a lot a lot of people over
the next 5-10 years will listen to this
is there anything that we haven't
serendipitously gone into you that maybe
you want to share I'd like to talk about
what I'm doing at the moment if I may
that's why I asked so about a year ago I
saw I joined Instagram about a year and
a half ago okay because I was having to
promote the good place and okay you know
they asked me to join Idol was anybody
ready yeah they asked me and they hadn't
really asked me before but now that the
show was growing they were just like
will you join social media and I kind of
joined it but didn't post anything and
then I started to finally about a year
and a half ago did you make an
ideological standpoint on that like
weddings like you were like I'm just not
gonna be about that prior to that I
profess I wasn't into the photo side if
they see you prefer gone I've become
more video friendly I was suddenly like
oh I'm more interested in this I will
tell you this that I think you could
crush this based on this is now on
intuition I think one of the most
interesting things going on on Instagram
that more people need to explore is to
take a photo regardless of its
production value and then genuinely
write a [ __ ] book like limit - the
limit like I've been fascinated by
Instagram as a blog has been a very
effective way for many different people
to communicate its how my activism is
spread so far but I so I joined it a
year and a half ago
like properly where I properly got
involved started posting sort of paying
attention following other people like
ingesting content and around the same
time I went I click that little mic my
what is it a microscope that microscope
magnify
it's like you should know this is some
Brits probably some British I clicked on
that and that is a very dangerous button
to press because you have no idea what
you boy yeah the explore button and so
explore exposes you oh I love when
people are like yeah and I'll grab there
like I'm talking now real friends don't
[ __ ] about what they do up and then I
grab their phone and hit explore I'm
like you go on into the report it's an
ass yeah not really in touch I'm like
the algorithm knows exactly what you're
Matt like like like it expected exposes
you quick but the algorithm also exposes
social media the algorithm exposes the
fact that that social media hunts you
down based on your gender and and based
on your age and me being a young woman
on Instagram at the Instagram was
sending me pictures that I didn't need
to see as a young woman and those are
images of very famous beautiful women
with numbers written across their bodies
and those numbers were not their net
worth because these are people like the
Kardashians Taylor's people are worth
tens of millions and I owe billions even
and I clicked on the pictures of them
and all of those numbers were just their
weight and I was like this wasn't their
account other accounts that were pushing
Rexach propaganda and they were just
like the [ __ ] there the post was written
underneath it being like you know these
people at this this height how much do
you weigh and then you had thousands of
comments little girls being like oh no
I'm the same height as Kendall Jenner
but I weigh this much and so I just
something snapped in me because once I
pressed it because of the [ __ ]
algorithm more and more posts like that
started coming up to me and like
suddenly I was just being bombarded with
this thinspiration all over again
just like when I was a teenager so I was
like okay enough I'm gonna go anyw off
I'm gonna go on the offense so I went
onto Twitter and I was like I posted
those posts I went on a rant and I said
this is what I weigh I wear my financial
independence my activism my
relationships the things that the eating
disorder I've overcome the struggles I'm
still coping with I weigh the sum of all
of my [ __ ] parts and wrote
[ __ ] kg underneath that and I just
posted it out I didn't have a very big
following at all I had like 16 thousand
followers on on Instagram and like maybe
75,000 on Twitter like wasn't huge
and it went viral immediately people
started sending me back there i way
pages of what they weigh and their
contributions to society and their
attributes that weren't in the physical
and it just became this movement i
thought it would be like maybe like the
ALS ice bucket challenge
unix and then gone and no one know what
the function about thirty times more
than most things yeah and i saw I
started an Instagram account thinking
I'll just put these up there so that
then they were there and everyone will
remember that they put their post Docs
they were super brave and now a year
later we're almost at a million and
growing and this is without a social
media team like this is just pure
organic it's people submitting that
listen when messages at home it's
there's nothing like it
and it's just like there's nothing like
it it shows you how diminished our sense
of self-worth is especially in women but
also in like gay men and non-binary
people there are so many people out
there who just feel so undermined well
where I think we need to really get to
to a thoughtful place is understand what
your that your statement
mmm-hmm is actually happening to
everybody oh yeah the biggest issue that
I'm telling a lot of my friends is go
into other websites with people that
don't believe in the same things you
believe and find how they feel like
they're being suppressed yeah like this
is the this is where empathy and
compassion and thoughtfulness and truly
because everyone's digging in mm-hmm
like people are digging in real heavy
right now yeah and I get so much amazing
feedback I have like a DM that feels
like a giant focus group into the
innermost feelings and thoughts of the
world and so this whole thing this
Instagram account turned into a global
movement and I was able to turn that
into petitions and then be able to get
those petitions into Parliament in the
United Kingdom and into Congress in New
York and I was able to you know I was
offered a meeting with Instagram who had
seen that my my following was growing
and that they really liked the
positivity of Iowa because it was a rare
safe space on Instagram and that's
something that Instagram want they
aren't these like evil bastards who want
everyone to starve themselves but they
have been complicit and allowing that to
continue and they are aware of that so
yeah but you know look and I'm just
gonna jump in like I think I think we
have to have very thoughtful
conversations of humans doing human
things yeah I mean there's a also have
like social responsibility we have if we
gonna open the door to young people we
have to do better at policing that space
of course right and so when I had that
meeting with them I was like okay I have
three days I'm gonna start petition and
just see where I get I've got two
hundred and fifty thousand signatures in
under three days and so I went to them
with that and I said look everyone is
aware of how annoying I am I'm only
going to get worse so you can either do
this with me or I'll just do this to you
and they were amazing they were so
unexpectedly immediately on board they
had been also aware of my petition and
they just moved faster than I ever could
have imagined six months later Facebook
and Instagram globally have made it
impossible for minors to be able to even
see weight loss products diet products
detox products cosmetic surgery
procedures you can't see it under 18 and
if you're over 18 and you see these
things that are like lose fifty five
pounds in 15 seconds you can report it
and it comes down immediately so this is
just the start of what needs to happen
because we need to deal with our entire
societal value of people and this
obsession with vanity but we we are on
the road to showing people that a
disobedient woman can make a big [ __ ]
difference that's always been the case
when the gates are open in our society
which is actually the true power of the
Internet we are actively demonizing all
of this while it actually is the
framework that people that come along
that can make change are using to make
change yeah and look who's been fighting
for this there are people with way less
privilege to me them in for sure but
unfortunately as I learned when I was 19
when I was not being allowed in as an
activist with the platform and the
privilege you can create huge change and
so I've made it my mission and I totally
understand the frustration of people who
feel like I got more credit but I have
been in this for 14 years and I've never
stopped and I was a big kid who got
bullied for their weight and then I was
the anorexic teenager so I do it so true
I do have the credentials to like back
up my passion listen again this goes
back the thematics of all this is
judgment when people talk about
privilege mm-hmm my genuine vibe on that
over the last two three years has been
in a very funny place which is because
we are able
to see ones happiness and mental status
we will never get to the actual
conversation of privilege exactly which
is the true privilege yeah of society is
what's going on in here but the funniest
thing is that I think you know people
are so quick to judge that no one ever
gave me a chance not no one loads of
people gave me a chance loads of people
women supportive but the people who have
been so suspicious of me I understand
that suspicion because so many people in
my industry don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about them but I do and they didn't
realize what I was planning let me just
finish baby so-and-so now what I've done
is I've hired this incredible team of
women and we've built this company now
and we're taking my way from Instagram
now onto a website and into a full
activism platform where we're now going
to lend my platform and my privilege to
the young people and the marginalized
people who never got a chance before
we're creating this space of content
where you will finally wherever you are
from whoever you are whatever you look
like you will see someone like you
reflected back on that page and so
that's something that I feel super proud
of and like passionate about what's that
going to be called
I weigh based on the movement of the
Instagram account it's called I way and
it started off as this statement around
body image but really it was about our
emotional health and our mental health
well-being and that's what it is some
people think it's a body positive
account it's not it's a mental health
movement everything that I am the most
invested in in the world are you worried
about the literal name skewing so
literal to you know to your point it's a
it's a higher play from it but the name
is so literal in its interpretation
potentially seconds to see I also am the
one who says names are made and like get
changed all the time
I was just curious genuinely curious if
you thought about fascinated by like
positioning yeah so I was just curious
like did that ever like obviously
there's so much equity in that some
people think I'm a way way which is
really roll up on my way yeah
I went running a book to promote and I
was like too close man too close go away
how many people think my name is Garvey
like what like people Garvey I'm like
men interesting you read like I do I
always feel warm to those people no no
and also like the point if I win is it's
it's what you weigh on the inside I
totally owe therefore it's all about
your it's it's your inner work I think
you I think and I am aware that you're
you're taking it to the place you want
to take it and that just that
nonetheless let's move on parting shots
what do you got
what's your favorite which what are you
obsessed with right now and in a
light-hearted way like like a drink like
like like a single person that you're
following for the last two days a song
you played out there like just a fun
lightweight what are you obsessed with
right now I'm obsessed with people you
don't understand I know I do
I'm obsessed I genuinely [ __ ] do I've
always been and like you know I was I
was a kid who grew up like I was a lot
of abuse in my childhood like I met all
kinds of different people way too young
and I had all kinds of different
experiences of people way too young I
mean it's not great but your support on
the end well that ends up meaning that
it's great yeah important to be
thoughtful to the people who perhaps are
still going through the bad of it and
haven't yet you're not saying just
because it's no this way that that's not
going on for that ahead sure yeah yeah
yeah I feel like I still would have been
smart an observant with just a touch
less trauma but nonetheless adversity is
foundational for sure and by the way
combination of wait go when adversity is
foundational when you also have the
tremendous privilege of having access to
therapy and help okay
that's important to remember a lot of
people just get left in weather and by
the way and by the way let's define
words yeah adversity versus massive
trauma yeah you know so without you know
you're being vague so I can't I can't no
assumptions I think back to those cut
right because I think it's so I don't
know we're living through I'm so [ __ ]
grateful to be living through this time
yeah I think it is a very I think look I
think we've all
no matter how young we are we've all
lived through times where things are a
little bit more kind of like stable like
it's intriguing to live through real
[ __ ] change and there's real
monumental scaled change that will play
out over the next century this is why my
obsession is coming from is that I think
the reason that I was like you know a
victim of so many different types of
abuse is because people were holding in
all of their feelings and all of their
thoughts all of the time you know I grew
up in Britain in the 90s yeah and and
everyone's racism was like very
insidious like hidden but it would like
burst out of them and so I think what
was so interesting is the fact that I've
come through that time into now where
everyone's feelings are just spilling
out of them and it's like oh my god
everyone is unlocking I find that
fascinating because and good because
it's great good I'm with you hell I
think the show much healthy listen I'm
watching how you're navigating how
you're speaking what you're talking
about like I'm a buyer of what you're
putting down the shadows of our lives
are the jails yeah that's where the bad
[ __ ] is I'm with you and I reckon when
you I really love your realism it's a
thing that I haven't heard this podcast
before which is why I was like but I but
I watch all your videos and I just think
just wait the fact that you just cut
straight through the [ __ ] and you just
tell the truth or you tell your truth
whatever it's my and honestly with what
I think now that I get even better sense
of you why I understand some people they
think that there's there's always the
other side of the coin they but I
understand now why you we have a lot of
similarities obviously a lot of
differences I think you can sense much
like I'm feeling during this whole time
together that when one shoots it
straight or keeps it real there are two
very [ __ ] different versions of that
one somebody's doing that to suppress
two other versions somebody actually is
genuine intent that hopes its the
variable that helps one mmm-hmm and I'm
grateful that you understood that yeah I
appreciate that about you I was
genuinely how I feel like I feel like
why not like I'm so good at the idea of
pretense I can't be bothered like I lost
so many years of my life already I'm not
interested in small talk or wasted
everyone by the likeness and here's why
Oh everyone's losing in that scenario
nobody's winning no the person that's
deploying it ultimately becomes
resentful
the person on the other side is not
getting any benefit it's a lose-lose
[ __ ] situation
it's sullied the whole situation the
whole interaction is sullied and and
pointless and no idea what solid is but
I'm sure that's exactly right
Sulli [ __ ] right thank you thank you
this is a great